la société française va mal vous l'avait
dit et bien des égards je crois que je
suis d'accord avec vous non pas que tout
irait mal gardons tout ça n'est pas du
tout le sens de votre question gardons
nous de dire ou de penser que tout irait
mal en france ce n'est pas le cas nous
avons des atouts extraordinaires vous
les savez et notons ne tombons pas dans
ce travers français au pessimisme et à
l'auto dénigrement mais soyons lucides
comme vous l'êtes et disons qu'à côté de
ces atouts à côté de ses chances
remarquable que nous avons en france
nous connaissons des difficultés
sérieuses des difficultés économiques
des difficultés sociales et peut-être
même aussi je ne dirais pas des
difficultés morales car le terme aurait
pu avoir un sens il ya longtemps il ya
aujourd'hui un sens qui ne correspond
plus à la réalité
enfin en tout cas au sens que nous lui
donnons mais des difficultés alors
disons les politiques
qu'est ce qu'une nation se référant bout
se réfère index ce plébiscite quotidien
cette volonté quotidienne de s'inscrire
dans une longue histoire qui nous
dépassent très largement dont la
complexité nous dépassent très largement
et de vivre ensemble et de construire
quelque chose ensemble une nation ce
n'est pas simplement regarder le passé
et le prendre tel qu'il est c'est
construire à partir de l'espace et s'est
imaginé l'endroit où nous voulons
aboutir en tant que peuple et bien deux
points de vue là de ce point de vue là
nous avons manifestement une difficulté
à nous projeter
certains remettent en cause
explicitement les fondements du pacte
républicain
d'autres
à mon sens de façon plus insidieuse et
probablement plus dangereuse remettent
en cause ses fondements sans le dire
et lorsque on revient sur l'idée de
liberté
lorsque l'on revient sur l'idée
d'égalité en droits
lorsque l'on revient sur le principes de
l'état de droit de l'autorité de l'état
lorsque l'on revient sur le respect qui
est dû à chaque citoyen lorsqu'on leur
revient lorsque l'on revient sur l'idée
même de civisme
si notre régime s'appelle la république
c'est parce qu'elle a eu des
prédécesseurs et une des vertus
cardinales de la république à rome
c'était le civisme c'est à dire non pas
l'exemplarité de tel ou tel mais bien
l'idée que chacun chacun quelles que
soient ses responsabilités qu'il soit
élu ou non et dieu sait qu'on aimait les
élections aussi à rome
dépositaire d'une parcelle de ce qu'est
le bien commun et bien ce civisme
on le voit comme progressivement dissous
le respect de l'état on le voit tous les
jours
remis en cause non pas parce que l'état
serait irréprochable
c'est pas parce que l'état soit
irréprochable qu'il faut le respecter
cela parce qu'il saurait mieux que les
autres
ça se saurait c'est parce qu'il est
l'émanation de notre nation et parce
qu'il est là pour faire respecter un
certain nombre de règles qui sont
essentiels à l'intérêt commun l'autorité
de l'état
c'est la capacité monsieur le sénateur à
faire respecter la loi c'est la loi qui
doit prévaloir dans un état de droit
c'est la loi qui doit prévaloir dans la
république la loi et on voit bien que la
force parfois la met en cause on voit
bien que telle ou telle bande que tel ou
tel groupe parfois que tel ou tel
individu veut la faire céder
vous la brise et me la remettre en cause
ce n'est pas un combat récent vous savez
bien monsieur le sénateur c'est un
combat éternel mais c'est un combat qui
aujourd'hui dans notre pays se pose avec
peut-être encore plus d'acuité qu'il ne
s'est posé dans les années qui
précédaient c'est un fait et bien face à
cela il faut je le crois essayer non pas
de faire taire les débats politiques ils
sont indispensables et jamais il ne faut
les faire taire mais essayez derrière
les débats politiques de dessiner cet
esprit de concorde sur l'essentiel pas
surtout sur l'essentiel sur les valeurs
de la république
il faut soutenir ceux qui font le combat
de la république ministre de l'intérieur
a mille fois raison de soutenir les
forces de l'ordre elles sont au coeur de
ce combat pour la république mais elles
ne sont pas les seuls elles ne sont pas
les seuls la république est née aussi
avec les professeurs la république est
née aussi avec les administrateurs ce
qu'ils construisaient ceux qui
organisaient avec ses représentants de
la force publique
nous leur devons le respect tous et
parfois parce que nous avons le droit de
les critiquer nous allons un peu au delà
et nous les dénigrent ont parfois nous
leur donc nous ne leur donnons pas
toujours les moyens de mettre en oeuvre
leur mission la question vous poser très
large monsieur le sénateur et je sais
que vous et moi nous pourrions disserter
des heures sur ce sujet mais pour moi la
république
ce sont des principes simples c'est
l'état de droit c'est le respect de
l'état
c'est l'autorité de l'état et c'est au
delà de tout ça peut être encore plus le
civisme qui fait que être un citoyen ce
n'est pas simplement être un homme qui a
des droits
c'est être un homme ou une femme qui a
des droits et des devoirs
je me suis toujours à titre personnel
monsieur le sénateur étonné de ce qui à
l'époque où le service militaire était
obligatoire vous faisait des leçons
longue comme le bras sur la république
et qui parfois avait eu la faiblesse
trouvé la solution d'échapper au service
militaire
elle nous connaissons tous ceux là c'est
le contraire du service et c'est parfois
des tentations qui sont très
individuelle est très personnel
voilà ce que je vais vous dire de sur le
sénateur monsieur quartiers chez le
premier ministre
la république c'est la liberté c'est
l'égalité c'est la fraternité c'est la
laïcité mais l'état c'est aussi le
garant de l'unité de la nation
et lorsque la société de plus en plus
violente est de plus en plus fracturées
alors il faut s'appuyer pleinement sur
ceux qui défendent la république et on
ne peut pas au nom de la liberté
accepter n'importe quel type de
contestation de critiques ou de violence
et le rôle de la police de la république
le rôle de la gendarmerie à l'intérieur
du pays sont essentiels pour soutenir
cette république pour garantir
l'autorité de l'état pour être les
représentants de ce que l'avenir doit
réserver à l'ensemble des français
de la même manière que c'est le rôle de
nos forces armées à l'extérieur la seule
chose monsieur le premier ministre que
l'ensemble des français vous demande
oui nous devons respecter les forces de
l'ordre oui nous devons respecter les
forces de sécurité en france et ailleurs
mais nous avons aussi tous nous dire que
les critiques violentes ne peuvent pas
être acceptées que la police comme la
gendarmerie sont des corps par
définition au service de la république
il peut y avoir des fautes personnelles
et il doit y avoir des sanctions mais il
doit y avoir toujours toujours le
respect de ceux qui défendent la
république